the full council meeting
we don't have any members of the public
here but um
i will just go through
the uh fire procedures we don't have any
fire drills planned but uh
if the fire alarm does go off the usual
procedure is to follow the directions of
the officers and be confirmed
uh item one do you have any apologies
sir
yes chair apologies from councillor
jones
councillor hutchins councillor dart
councillor inch
councillor rossi and councillor hawkins
although we may be late
okay
uh we don't have any members of the
public here but tom hasn't got anyone
wishing to speak
three on the agenda uh declarations of
interest so we will know the score by
now that if there are any interests that
can need to be raised
item four is agreement it
items on the agenda this evening
item five is to consider correspondence
or any other business
brought forward by the chair i haven't
got anything recently
item six to answer questions submitted
under procedural rule a9
there haven't been anywhere
so item seven is planning policy
governance on pages three to
thirty-three and sean harrington
planning manager will present the report
shown
[Music]
uh thank you can members hear me clearly
yes thank you
um as members will be aware from the
agenda the purpose of the report is to
the revised government's arrangements
relating to local planner
and wider planning policy
such a review formed a resolution of
full council
at a meeting of the 14th december 2020
existing governance arrangements take
the form of the local plan working group
which is an informal non-decision-making
group
therefore any formal decisions that need
to be taken are required to go to each
individual council that being north
devon council and torres district
council
existing working group comprises four
tourist council members and whilst
offering a number of benefits does lack
wider member and public participation
this report therefore seeks revised
joint governance arrangements in the
form of a joint planning policy
committee
the terms of reference are laid out in
your reports so i won't repeat it in
detail
however it is proposed that the
committee will be formed by seven
members from each partner council
including the leader and lead members
for economy
environment
climate planning housing and community
to ensure continued flexibility the
joint committee would be able to appoint
task teams or working groups to consider
certain
matters report back to joint committee
such groups could meet virtually as they
would not be an individual
decision-making body
your officers feel that there are a
number of benefits from a joint
committee including efficiency of
process
additional transparency
wider prep of membership
flexibility provided by the working
groups
further commitment to joint planning
within northern devon
and efficient use of resources
members should be aware that
decision-making powers of joint
committee would not extend the final
adoption of any future local plan which
would have to be referred back to each
individual full council
a similar recommendation is being taken
now at ndc northern council
simultaneously with this meeting
and i would ask that members consider
and the greek recommendations laid out
within the report
i believe the leader of the council
councilor james would now like to say a
few words
[Music]
fans are a key component of the planning
system they shape how land use and
places will change and develop in the
future is when the local plans are being
prepared therefore the councils and
communities can have the most influence
over shaping the future of the district
therefore it is important that all of us
as community leaders actively engaging
the plan
review the process
and in formulation of a new local plan
in order to have our say about how we
would like our trans village and
countryside to change and develop us
it is essential that the foundations are
laid for a good local plan and that is
why we're here to see them good
governance is at the heart of good
transparent decision making
the joint committee arrangements
that are proposed here cement our
partnership with north carolina council
and ensure that there's a broad range of
issues that are important to the
communities of both councils as well as
as well represented we have learned the
lesson from the evolution of the last
plan
and understand that it will be
beneficial for everybody to be made
included in the decision making
and the
formalization that's made
transparent and efficient as the new
plan progresses to the respective full
council adoption
as leader of the council it's been my
stated ambition to ensure that
production of a local plan
enables communities and businesses to
flourish
as well as to protect the landscape and
the buildings we love
i've been involved in planning for many
years and i'm convinced that the joint
committee will help us deliver a better
local plan
that will shape the future of our
district and that's why i'm happy to
propose a recommendation
you know it is important that we all
take part it's important that it's all
transparent and obviously using the
workshops we can all have to say about
it rather than
just the committee so
on that basis and i'd also
like to say i'm pleased that sean is
leading on it certainly from our side
hopefully the whole project but i'm not
going to get into
it so
i'm convinced that we've got a team in
college that can deliver this as our
part of it and i'm expecting the same
from north devon
so on that basis i will recommend it
pastor watson and thank you for your
second
secondly
well thank you for that um before we
take it to the vote um your members got
any points that they would like
senator hayes
yeah um
it's very good that this is going to be
open much more widely to members of our
membership and
more transparency
do i take that the minutes will be
published
and circulated
thank you captain james yes it's a
formal committee so it's a public
committee um following the normal sort
of procedure um with public minutes and
gender published
council branson
[Music]
however
are we really wasting our time let's
look at the political reality who's in
charge of planning now with government
you know michael go wasn't he the
minister who overruled everybody in
order to allow stern upon to go ahead as
a development
yes it was him
now of course trouble is at the moment
as long as a conservative party are
taking donations on a hundred thousand
from developers
and their comrades in russia then i
think you know anything goes and that is
going to be the reality
of course this plan will take a while to
develop so hopefully things might have
changed by the time it actually gets
published that's my hope so whatever
committees to suffer their committee
joint committee aside
the works will actually
have some chance of bearing fruit but
i'm not being cynical i'm just being
very
thank you potentially
sorry yeah that's what i was just
wondering
magnificent
is the makeup of the committee uh an
existence notion
so thank you chair thank you
um yes suggested to be the leader and
lead members for economy environment
climate planning housing community
all in favor please
this looks pretty unanimous to me
the record was anyone against
an abstention
so that's who you know
item eight on the agenda is uh northern
devon futures which is pages 34 to 50 on
the chief executive statement
[Music]
it's probably
timely for us now to consider the vision
for northern devon um and so far as it
would sit and fit in nicely with the
progression of the joint local plan
so members may recall that sean mcknee
the principal and chief executive of
petrog came before council
back almost two years ago now back in
2019
and presented to members a vision about
bringing together all the key partner
organizations across northern devon to
develop a kind of strategic vision for
the the area
um
so it's bringing together some of those
organizations that have similar
aspirations to
both councils and have major involvement
influence
in the the way things operate in the in
the area in terms of the economy the
environment education
health and skills and so forth so we can
use the strengths of
that partnership um to put northern
devon on the map to lobby to get uh
to get more funding to the area
unfortunately the the pandemic for pay
to the progress that was being made on
the partnership um so it was kind of put
on the back of the inner whilst the
impacts of the pandemic were dealt with
but as we've emerged from the pandemic
um sean mcnay ken miles myself along
with uh colleagues from
uh the hospital trust have been working
on developing um what the partnership
might look like who should be involved
and so forth um so members i'm sure
you'll recall when you approved the
strategic plan uh back in october last
year uh one of the key principles of
that was developing a long-term vision
for northern german bringing all
relevant partners together i think
whilst at the time that was initially
around the the local economy
fema the strategic plan clearly it has a
match across much wider crosstalk
feeling than just the economy
uh so you'll note from appendix 49
um on the sorry the appendix page 439
that whilst economy innovation and
skills is a key part of the
program
uh climate emergency place community
health and well-being children and young
people um also represent as key actions
for pulling together what we want to uh
what we want is a vision for the area so
it must include all of these factors if
we can improve the lives of our
residents business communities and
visitors to the area
you'll note from the draft report um the
the proposed organizations and
individuals who have already been
approached to perform that strategic
board that's on page 46 and the proposed
makeup of the the action groups
um so torridge is one of the the
partnership bodies of one of the bodies
part of the partnerships asked to
consider the document and vision and
feedback any comments if um as necessary
uh it's proposed that the the leader and
i represent storage on the strategic
board alongside other chief execs and
leaders of different organizations
it's not meant to be a
local authority public sector run
organization you'll note from the the
list of those
on the members and it's much wider than
that although it has got um political
representation the leader of uh torridge
council
north devon council uh councillor rufus
gilbert from devon county council and
the two mps jeffrey cox and celine
um you'll note from the the charts that
um
we've kind of built in a dedicated
secretariat to make sure each of these
groups are able to operate as well as
the strategic board
there's no additional cost
that will be sourced from opposite time
from within torridge north denver petroc
and the healthcare trust and that's to
ensure the the partnership move forward
effectively
we're planning to hold the first
partnership board later this month
where the the board members are asked to
consider the vision which is on page 36
of your report
which is the vision of the partnership
is that by 2015 northern devon is
healthy prosperous sustainable and
recognized for its aspiration innovation
and ability to get things done a place
where we are or where we all are able to
succeed and no one is left behind
so it's kind of
a good time as well to start talking
about this with new funding
opportunities being presented and
principally the the leveling up fund
which clearly as an area we'd aspire to
be putting bridge forward forward
um so
this um hopefully uh will enable us to
work with
northern denton with the partnership
have a greater voice across the area in
what we want to achieve
um so i'll i'll stop there happy to take
any questions and there's two
recommendations to the report trailer on
page 35
uh the t
join partnership commits the vision
and the leader be nominated to represent
torridge on the strategic partnership
board
thank you for that steve um any
questions
thanks question
yeah i don't know how many councillors
actually looked at the very last page
of this report and clicked on the link
my ruling
you get maddest diagram i've ever seen
and it's got things like uh vacants
creatives meanwhile uses tdc
uh vacants windows scheme tdc
um can ask what what's that all about i
mean this diagram
it's
completely crackers to me
[Music]
it's on the very last page of our agenda
there's a link
it's uh
quite populated so yeah
something now guest editing my page
[Music]
there's
numerous
groups doing lots lots of good things
um lots of
time being spent putting things in
talking about different things and
there's no kind of coordination of how
all these groups operate
so you've got a lot of
influential
people spending time in different groups
not necessarily achieving
[Music]
the only reason i asked was
i've never heard of those things and
it's something apparently tdc has signed
up this i've never heard of him
on facebook
well presumably we will sign up with
them if we agreed
okay
it doesn't actually say nx5 as an
example of mapping the current and
possible investment projects
so i think it's just an example
anybody
list uh it's been sent this document has
been sent out to all those organizations
the feedback and or to accept
support as the same reason is coming to
you as members of this council gone to
members of north dakota council so
instead of wishlist
many of them i think have accepted it
um
we had a meeting this afternoon to start
setting the agenda the first partnership
board i
can't remember the numbers but a number
of i think there's 12 to 15 who have
accepted the appointment for that first
meeting and the members said they wish
to be part of it can't make that first
feat
clearly it needs to
actually be formulated officially before
you can actually um you know run with a
problem
thank you mr chairman two or three
points page 44.
it must include representation from the
two district councils
so the decisions been made for us
having said that i read through the
wonderful aims and aspirations of it
and note the complete absence of
agriculture in the rural areas
we've got to go with it but it's just
county council's not involved here
because they do education
they are there there is representation
okay good that's the question health and
social care is really important because
if you want integrated care
we need to make sure that every country
is represented
any other countries before we take it to
the moment i'm sorry james yeah
because
i'm down there but the point of it is
that both steve and i sit on several
committees they're all doing
some doing the same thing some are doing
different things what we're trying to do
is to get it focused a bit so that we
can deliver stuff and there is no doubt
that we have to be organized i take the
point from coach brent and we don't know
what government is going to be but like
with the local plan we got to the end of
2023 to do it we've got to do it and
this is another thing where
there's lots of talk going on from
government about where county and
unitaries are going and the thing is
that we have to be organized because if
we're not we will miss the vote on
things like the leveling up the uh
the other funding
so we have to sort of
set an agenda for what we want for this
area and northern devon
you know it's been neglected in the past
we've all stood here over the last well
i've been here maybe 20 years now
complaining about nobody knows where
tolerance is nobody
cares about northern devon and i went
with steve to clumpton last week where
you could see when you look at the map
about infrastructure how neglected we
are up here so we have got to get
together we have got to form these
groups and we need to focus they still
could be going to one group on a monday
in a different group on a tuesday
talking about the same thing and
achieving nothing on the wednesday so
the aim of this is to try and bring
stuff together particularly stuff i've
been doing today on the skills for young
people
um you know but we're being told um i've
been talking education today that say
that a few years ago and actually funny
enough it was
under
a
politician we spoke about today where
skills were cancelled in schools and it
was all paperwork education and now
we're realizing that we're short of
engineers we're short of
players and people like that so
you know there's something called the
esp which is coming out of petrol that
we will all be working with which is
educational skills board um
so
yes it's a bit unwieldy it's a little
bit
pops up high in the sky it's a little
bit of a wish list but if we don't move
forward we're just left behind and not
more importantly our young people will
be left behind and you know it's alright
when we're retired and we think
we're okay
but we have got to plan for the future
and we can't waste opportunities to
actually form these groups and work at
it you know it's like everything we're
doing at the moment we work on it
hopefully we're successful but if you
don't work on it you won't be successful
so thank you for preparing today
chair i'd just like to follow on what
councillor hicks was wrote
it is a concern
that the agricultural sector
is not represented as an industry body
of which the agricultural sector is the
largest industrial base
in either of the districts involved
and it is extraordinary that actually
there is no
representation there the only
industrial representation on this board
is all urban based industry or urban
focused industry and
you are missing
50 at least
of the industrial base
across the two districts
um whether it be in terms of of um
size of employer permanent employer
or indeed capital spend
the agricultural sector
dwarfs everything else must be
represented
that's the purpose of this evening is to
to feedback and that that's that is to
feedback comment so
i would like to come
[Music]
basically it's very vague though it
talks about smart agriculture
by the way
um but it is there but uh i agree with
you that doesn't need to be a much
stronger um input from the actual sector
um i was a bit surprised to hear
clockton
my daughter lives in clarkson i go down
there quite wriggly um if you go to
compton the high street is in terminal
decline it's the worst down i've ever
seen
it's got lots of infrastructure yes
he's got major problems uh i have to
point out that again it takes up
something that's already been said our
county councillors need to be involved
here because it's still wrangled me and
i suspect council of branson knows what
i'm going to say
um county council sold off the old
recreation center at the top of
biddeford high street
and they paid for clumpton library
and we need our county councillors to
start reversing that flow of funds from
the north and south
that's
um
oh
well obviously
um i will be reporting back to you and i
will expect you to ask me if you do
about the other stuff you want to know
about um as far as agriculture is
concerned
exactly it's not showing clearly but i'm
actually working on a project with
exeter university which is actually
feeding into some of this um to do with
carbon zero stuff in farming so there is
there it's all going on and that's the
point i was trying to make there is so
much little bits going on we just need
to get it focused and obviously we need
to ensure agriculture in it you know
it's something i do is a part-time job
these days
particularly at the moment when i've got
a load of cattle stranded in the middle
of the table right and i'm playing for
the tamar to go down so yeah it will be
involved i will report back to you um
and i just want to focus as we go
forward you know and we just got to do
it i'm playing
and i'm not that i want another job i
can assure you
thank you kevin langford thank you i
just want to mention something about the
children and young people
actually who they get to represent them
but um
petrarch is obviously basically based um
andy cotton
ceo of tarka learning that's multiple
base so i would really hope that the
secondary heads and primary heads
representation
comes from outside the barnstable area
and gives other areas um an opportunity
to be represented
um
it is on the list
however small it is there but clearly i
would come to james's background i would
be very surprised if it isn't on
on the next summary
[Music]
you haven't asked either the
the
regional uh rep of the nfu or
some similar organization
it's not appropriate for the leader to
cover the agricultural bit at the moment
although he is professionally involved
in that but his successor may not be or
whatever so that's a bonus but actually
uh i believe that there should be an
industrial leader uh
deep in invo deeply involved and
knowledgeable in agriculture who's
actually in that list of personalities
who are actually on the board um
that's a very good point
um sure just just to
go back to councillor colton and
councillor newton so i don't think we
need to make a formal proposal the your
comments can be noted in the minutes and
i can feed back those comments uh to the
partnership board the recommendation uh
from the council is that we have a rep
we have the agriculture either from the
nfv or some other
body uh to probably
how can agriculture in this area in any
area be suddenly mine on the bottom and
we're just going to note
that in minutes now
this should be right at the top of the
achievement did everyone i hope watched
david attenborough the program on global
warming my god that doesn't tell us
and the way agriculture works
just we must
do something more formal
uh even if it's time together and using
our lead and his expertise to pull
to pull these different
pieces together
we've got to do better
well as has been said cancer laws you
know
people have made
their thoughts very clear that
agriculture needs to be central to this
uh this process and i'm sure that that
message will be taken back
that's a handset
yeah i mean looking at this list i'm
quite surprised on the climate emergency
the
northern biosphere
involved
[Music]
he's on the strategic board yeah
all i would say is we're looking very
detailed at the diagrams the principle
is there's a lot of stuff going on there
has been meetings in north devon with
the nfu um with the leaders and what's
happening is we're not always connected
so what we're trying to do is get a
board that is connected so we're
involved with all this going on as i
said earlier i've been doing work with
extra university we're feeding that
information into stuff so
the thing about it is i think it comes
before you tonight with the diagram
you've highlighted the stuff that
concerns you we can then take that back
to the board and get it included the
thing about it is it's the old saying
about being in the tech rather than
outside so
i know all that and i'm quite happy if
you've got follow-up stuff after the
meeting
um but i think
we don't get tied down with them my new
detail look at the principle is that we
need to look to work together we need to
be on board together and we need to put
what we want from college
into this because if we don't
we will be in the position where stuff
is going on and we don't know
so
i'm quite happy to be in the tent
fighting for us rather than saying
i'm concerned about this i'm concerned
about that and getting left out of the
tent
does that all make sense
sorry sure i think it's quite
significant there isn't that
representation on the actual action
group because you know it doesn't seem
to be it's not representing wildlife
biodiversity etc
which is very much part of your future
so i hope you take them forward
i'm sure
okay well if there's no other speakers
um
i'm going to propose this from the chair
that i'll just read out the
recommendations that
foreign futures partnership and commit
to its vision
and that the leader of this council be
nominated be a nominated representative
on the northern devon
futures strategic board i'll propose
that from the chair
mr newton seconded all in favor please
sean
thank you very much
okay
item nine petitions uh there are
repetitions
item 10 there are no notices of motions
and we don't have any part two items as
far as i'm aware
so
my meeting ends up